sa plaque a disparu de la façade
pourtant depuis ce matin son nom est sur
toutes les lèvres dans ce centre de
santé au téléphone tous les patients ont
la même crainte vis-à-vis des
prescriptions
voilà donc on essaye de les rassurer on
trouve nous on essaye de trouver des
solutions car depuis mai cette fausse
médecin a reçu des centaines de patients
la direction de filières is a porté
plainte
elle ne s'est douté de rien aucun signe
depuis sa prise de poste jusqu'à
dimanche jusqu'à lundi matin que je les
relever de ses fonctions
on n'a jamais eu à aucun moment une
plainte de qui que ce soit jamais c'est
surprenant d'ailleurs surprenant voire
choquant pour régine gauthier son mari
était un des patients de cette femme il
est en réanimation depuis six semaines à
chalon est selon elle il n'y a pas de
doute c'est la faute de l'incompétence
de cette fausse médecin je lui
pardonnerai jamais je souhaite qu'une
chose c'est que si un procès je me
trouve en face d'elle parce que
franchement je voudrais lui dire ce que
j'ai à lui dire pour me soulager un pour
un peu en espérant que mon mari se tire
de ce mauvais pas là où il est parce
qu'il est vraiment au fond du gouffre
comment cette femme de 36 ans at elle pu
exercer pendant près de quatre mois
c'est l'ordre des médecins de saône et
loire qui lui a délivré sa plaque
officielle du pays mais aussi les
conseillers ont été comme moi ils ont vu
le dossier
personne n'a tiqué sur l'authenticité du
diplôme on va voir quelle procédure en
va mettre en route mais il est bien
évident que il y a il y à une procédure
à revoir ce matin la femme a été
interpellée puis placée en garde à vue
selon son avocat son état de santé
pourrait être le coeur du problème
et peut-être pas justement c'est ça le
problème c'est pas une abolition du
discernement
c'est une altération donc elle est un
vraiment consciente et conséquences que
cela peut avoir une enquête a été
ouverte par le parquet pour exercice
illégal de la médecine
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui
blessures involontaires et faux et usage
de faux
elle risque cinq ans d'emprisonnement